so jeff bezos is not having a midlife
crisis or anything like that
he just built a rocket and took it into
outer space today the rocket is called
phallus one and jeff bezos the founder
of amazon
boarded it and was outside of our
atmosphere for 10 minutes he was
accompanied by his brother mark bezos as
well as an 82 year old woman
and an 18 year old student now a lot of
people missed the launch it happened
just after 8 a.m local time in texas
so we want to give you a quick replay of
what it looked like it's the world's
largest penile implant we didn't make
that up we didn't do it jeff bezos did
blame him we didn't want to put that on
television but he's the world's richest
man and we have no choice but to cover
his hobbies so we're not going to tell
you what that rocket's
actual name is he's calling it new
shepherd
here's what we're going to tell you
we're going to talk about his reception
as soon as jeff bezos
landed he was greeted by a throng of his
own reporters jeff bezos owns the
washington post you tend to get good
coverage
when you pay the people producing it
these are people who know how bad life
could be they could be working in an
amazon fulfillment center peeing in cans
for the rest of their life
so they immediately asked jeff bezos for
comment in a very respectful way
how did he respond here's his quote best
day
ever that was it not one small step for
man or something along those lines
he doesn't have time for rhetorical
flourishes like that he sells
books he doesn't write them but it
didn't matter our media were suitably
impressed they bowed before the richest
man best day
ever is three syllables but it's three
syllables they can understand very well
plus jb jeff bezos looked a lot like
them
the heavily quaffed tv anchors who spend
their day getting makeup
he'd had face fillers he was looking
suspiciously puffy before he went up to
space
therefore the commenters on television
were unanimous this was better than
anything
john glenn ever did
today was a big day exactly 52 years
since the first moon landing
another landmark moment in space
exploration here you see
billionaire amazon founder jeff bezos
and crew when they reached the edge of
space
and floated in zero gravity i don't know
why i
am like when i was nine and we stopped
and watched uh the original
john glenn launch i mean i feel like
that uh
i think that america wants to know about
this very much and
i don't blame us for doing wall-to-wall
because i think this is the most
this is one of the great business
stories of all time because it is
private equity
private enterprise going to space and
it really is obviously a big step for
future space tourism but it's a
remarkable step
in a mission that began more than two
decades ago when jeff bezos founded
blue origin your brother has been
determined
to advance space travel i want to know
what did it feel like
to be up there together when you locked
eyes
houston this is phallus one we're
leaving the atmosphere
oh they're so impressed it's
unbelievable
slobbering over jeff bezos now why do
they love jeff bezos so much
well we just found out today jeff bezos
is giving a hundred million dollars no
strings attached
to cnn contributor van jones
that's a lot of money it can buy a lot
of love
and they love him at cnn they love him
jeff bezos don't ever ask how do you
treat your employees jeff bezos how does
it feel to be china's biggest
retailer how exactly do you own the
capital city's local newspaper no one
asks those questions because
in the end everyone's hoping to get
money from jeff bezos
people who aren't getting money from
jeff bezos have a very different view of
him here's tulsi gabbard's view she's
not taking money from jeff bezos she
sent this today
the only problem i have with bezos is
rocket ship into outer space
is that it's going to come back you go
tulsi gabbard no wonder they hated you
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else